week nine
emerging the show me something draft
peter it begins with a trivia question
steve king
played linebacker for which nfl team
from 1973 to 1981.
cleveland browns
[Music]
oh no new england patriots i don't know
okay all right it was the patriots were
you a patriots fan growing up no did you
grow up as a patriots fan no
no i grew up in connecticut but at that
time
in the 60s you know the patriots were
just being born and so everybody in my
town
rooted for uh the new york giants that's
the game that's the team that was the
popular team and they were always on tv
so nobody i mean now in my town in
northern connecticut there's nobody who
isn't a patriots fan
but when i was growing up there was
nobody who was a patriots fan
yeah and you know what that makes sense
i mean people don't understand why folks
in west virginia are steelers fans
because there's a huge rivalry between
wvu and pittsburgh and people in west
virginia otherwise don't like pittsburgh
but
hey there's no pro sports teams in west
virginia so you got to glom on to the
steelers and the pirates and the
penguins all right first pick for me a
guy who played for the steelers and is
now back and show me something antonio
brown we've been waiting this is your
opportunity i can't wait to see what
antonio brown does the pressure is
clearly on him we'll see how he can
handle it and we'll see whether or not
tom brady maybe maybe forces it to him i
don't want to quite say force but you
know make sure that the ball goes his
way to get him involved to get him
feeling good to vindicate and validate
everything that brady has done to show
faith in antonio brown
show me something josh allen you know
for the first four weeks of the season
you were
playing as well as any quarterback in
the game
in the last four weeks
you're playing as well as trent dilfer
so and and i don't and that's not
being mean it's just being reality you
are a run-of-the-mill guy right now
and so to me when i look at this game
uh seattle at buffalo there's more at
stake than just buffalo
trying to protect
and and even lengthen its lead uh in the
afc east it's getting your quarterback
back on track
i i hate to go to this game because it's
relatively
meaningless
but at the same time show me something
jake lewton show me something
because this is a sixth round pick of
the jacksonville jaguars a year after
they used a sixth rounder on gardner
minshew and that created minshewmania i
don't know what
jake lewton has all i know is every time
i go to say his name i stop to make sure
it's not luke jayton so show me what you
got jake lewton just so i can get your
name right in the future
hey look this is a little bit of a
cliche and i'm sorry if it is but show
me something lamar jackson you have got
to help carry your team with all the
difficulties your defensive unit has
and find a way to win in indianapolis
and you know what mike i would not care
if uh if greg roman comes out with a
game plan where he runs it
45 times and where lamar jackson throws
it 18 times i don't care just find a way
to win a game and get yourselves back on
track against a quality opponent on the
road
yeah and and and that's the thing you
know
we assume the ravens and lamar jackson
have a chiefs problem it's quite
possible they have an elite team problem
and uh even though they have won some
big games against good teams it just
feels like when there's that extra layer
of something
something just doesn't add up the way
that it should all right last one for me
uh unless we go four rounds and maybe we
will i'm going i'm going gus bradley
show me something gus bradley you know
we talked about anthony lynn
last segment anthony lynn's not a
defensive guy gus bradley is a former
nfl head coach who's the defensive
coordinator of the la chargers they've
blown 17 point leads three times in the
last four games at some point gus has
got to do something with that defense we
always hear about how great that defense
is well when you're given a 17 point
lead by justin herbert in the offense
one of these games you got to hold it so
gus bradley it's time to hold that lead
show me something cam newton um you know
the new england patriots go uh to the
meadowlands in one of the worst games in
monday night history and i go back to
the giants and cardinals in 1983.
uh but this is
you know two teams combined two and
thirteen
uh and both of them out of it
uh but
the reason why i say show me something
cam newton this isn't just show me
something for this week show me
something for your career
take a team that has a woeful group of
skill position players
lift them
rising tide lifts all boats lift your
team like an mvp great quarterback is
supposed to do it's on your shoulders
cam newton
yeah you know i agree with you and i
don't think the monday night game is
going to be quite that bad i actually
think
that you know the jets as they go into
their bye week this is their last best
chance to win a game maybe for a while
who would have ever imagined that the
patriots game would be one that the jets
could look at and say hey maybe we have
a chance in this so but if cam newton
plays the way he's capable of playing
and makes the decisions that he made
earlier in the season it shouldn't be a
close game all right let's go to round
four i'm gonna go with tua we talked
about tua earlier we we both agree that
tua gets an eye
for his performance last week well
apples to apples both guys wearing
number one and apparently the elias
sports bureau tracks this it's been at
least 20 years since the two starting
quarterbacks of an nfl game war number
one if you're gonna wear number one you
to play like number one and we know what
kyle murray is going to do this is to
his opportunity and it's more than
opportunity it's a mandate to go out
there and prove that the dolphins made
the right choice when they selected tua
over justin herbert peter
show me something daniel jones
um look at some point he's really gonna
have to show something
okay and and look i'm not saying that
his career
uh is is gonna be a disaster i'm not
saying that but you almost feel like
he's at a little bit of a crossroads
right now midway through his second
season he cannot cure the turnover bug
the new york giants should have beaten
the tampa bay buccaneers monday
would have beaten the tampa bay
buccaneers if not for two idiotic
turnovers by daniel jones
okay so in every game he's played in the
nfl he is either fumbled i didn't say
lost fumble but he is either fumbled or
thrown in interception or both
that must stop
and i'm not saying if you pull them and
put in colt mccoy at some point the rest
of this year that the season's over but
at some point at some point
you know joe judge is going to look his
team in the eye and he's going to look
at them and say hey listen we got to win
this game this week and i'm putting colt
mccoy in because we're turning it over
too much
so i think this is the kind of game a
winnable game for the new york giants
washington's the only team they can beat
and and and this is the kind of game
that daniel jones has to get right
whether they win or lose this game
daniel jones has got to stop
being this comedy of errors quarterback
and one thing i've been saying about
dana jones all week he's just good
enough to put himself in position to
make that big mistake that blows the
game it would be better if he was just
worse across the board then he wouldn't
be making these notable significant
mistakes that turn victory into defeat
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports